mesdames messieurs bonsoir le débat sur
l'immigration et l'absence de politique
claire peuvent-ils aller jusqu'au rejet
brutal de deux enfants dans une école
parce qu'ils sont immigrés cela se passe
à montfermeil dans la seine saint denis
le seuil de tolérance mythe ou réalité
l'enquète d'hélène risacher
c'est dans cette cité 9 cabines depuis
un mois la famille erban le père
algérien vite en france depuis 21 ans
ses deux plus grands enfants aujourd'hui
8 et 9 ans sont interdits l'école par
décision du maire qui refuse les
nouveaux arrivants depuis quelques
semaines et nous avait pour l'instant on
ne peut pas les locales et les gosses
d'immigrés à montfermeil où on parle
quand les noms on sent malheureux
notamment à l'école dessus at avis
qu'est-ce qui m'a dit que l'on la
première semaine je suis à l'antenne
boulot il m'a dit papa je commence à
avoir mal à rester à la maison que vous
saviez quand vous avez déménagé que vous
êtes arrivé ici que pour vos enfants ce
serait pas possible d'aller à l'école
non je ne vais pas je leur ai su ça je
leur ai pas dit ménagers
je vais là je reste au je suis pour le
maire de montfermeil mohamed art ban
aurait dû savoir et ne pas s'installer
dans sa commune
à noter pourtant que ce logement lui a
été attribué par l'office des hlm
il n'a pas choisi la ville la mesure
discriminatoire qui touche ses enfants a
reçu l'appui du conseil municipal la
droite a voté pour la gauche s'est
abstenue
pour le maire les classes envahi
d'immigrés pose des problèmes
ce n'est pas je le précise ni du racisme
n'est de la xénophobie
cette mesure nous était dictée pour
une question de santé de population
comprenait 25 % l'étranger c'est à la
limite du supportable
est ce que je fait qu'il n'est peut-être
pas bout sur le plan des grands
sentiments et bien je dois le faire il
ya une réalité c'est que le maire est
actuellement est dans une situation de
non-droit l'omert dans ses attributions
est tenu de veiller à l'obligation
scolaire des enfants résidant sur sa
localité
c'est une exigence et c'est un de ces
deux voies pour le mouvement contre le
racisme cette histoire est symbole d'une
escalade de plus en plus on attribue à
l'immigration tous les problèmes qui
nous touchent aujourd'hui on va jusqu'à
faire d'enfant
l'enjeu d'une bataille mal définis car
les petits art bahn ne sont pas les
seuls à être interdits d'école